a VW Beetle makes its way through sandy
dunes on the north frisian island of
search but this is no ordinary bug
called the dune
it's a reincarnation of the legendary
beach buggies of the 1960s so how does
the dune differ from other VW beetles
take a closer look and you'll see that
its body is raised by 50 millimeters so
the car can go off-road VW has decided
to put the dune into series production
and 2016 for now it's just a show car so
small changes will likely be made to its
design
the dune is also 4.8 centimeters wider
than the standard beetle the chrome on
the rims and side skirts glistens in the
Sun the car's rear end is dominated by
two eye-catching spoilers they don't
just look sporty
they're also practical allowing a pair
of skis to be affixed to this show car
unfortunately that won't be the case
when the model goes into series
production
the dunes flashy paint job has caught
the attention of lasse Baron shake he
takes the time to give us his
impressions of the beach buggy
he says the workmanship on the outside
is very good and the chrome looks classy
Lhasa
especially likes the dunes curves under
the hood a tried and true turbocharged
direct-injection engine delivers 155
kilowatts of sporty performance
the market-ready dune will feature
front-wheel drive as the beetle doesn't
yet use the VW group's modular toolkit
system it's not so easy to produce an
all wheel drive version so for now VW
has no plans to introduce one monster
says that in spite of its raised
suspension the dude drives really well
grips the road even in windy areas and
it's seeds provide nice support so you
don't slide back and forth even when
taking curves quickly in a Corvette but
undimmed he says the controls and
instruments are well laid out and easily
reachable the scissor console is very
nice the gear selector pleasant and the
passenger compartment well finished he
likes a lot if had me that would the
contrasting color scheme is also carried
through on the inside the retro grab
handle in front of the passenger seat
gives the dune that old-style beetle
look the handle won't feature in
standard bugs due to safety issues or
the passenger side airbag the doones
ultra modern central display stands in
stark contrast to the retro feel
the oil gauge clock and boost gauge are
also presented as a matching trio the
center console looks clear and
uncluttered drivers shift gears using
the six-speed dual-clutch gearbox
but there is one thing about the bug
that bugs Lhasa and it has to do with
beetles iconic shape yeah he says when
reversing visibility is not that great
but that's the only real - he's noticed
VW hopes the car will revive the dune
buggy lifestyle so what does lassie
think of it the blood is a lifestyle car
that's nice for the summer too bad it's
not a convertible he says but for a
close top car it's great a real summer
car the model VW does plan to offer an
open top version of the dune but beach
buggy fans will have to be patient both
the convertible and standard versions
won't be ready to hit the sand dunes
until 2016 at the earliest